[Musica]
ma non vedo Fede serio secchezza
Buongiorno
buongiorno buongiorno
a tutti intanto Fate un applauso di
nuovo a Gabriele e a tutti i ragazzi Io
sto vedendo un'energia
incredibile Questa mattina
è davvero è davvero Pazzesco Sono molto
contento di essere qui a me diciamo il
compito ma è un onore quello di aprire
la giornata di oggi dopo due anni per
altro Quindi senza pressione
tranquillamente
Io sono Gianluca Gazzoli mi presento Mi
fa un sacco piacere essere qui Io nella
vita faccio un po' di cose quindi magari
ci conosciamo perché magari mi avete
ascoltato ci siamo sentiti in radio su
Radio Deejay Magari avete visto qualcuno
dei miei contenuti sui social magari in
televisione Magari appunto al basement
che è stato citato poco fa avete
ascoltato qualche puntata del podcast
Infatti per questo per me è un po'
difficile come dire
presentarmi No sai quando devi stringere
la mano io sono Gianluca e io dico ciao
Io sono Gianluca Gazzoli faccio cose
perché poi Appunto questo questo è
inizialmente anni fa tutto questo era un
problema Perché l'Italia è un paese che
in qualche modo deve sempre incasellarti
oggi lo sapete meglio di me se siete qui
oggi se non fai più cose Inizia a
diventare tutto un po' Inizia a
diventare tutto un po' un problema io
sono dico sempre sono cresciuto sognando
di fare un mestiere che non esiste più e
ne faccio tanti che invece non non
esistevano io Sognavo di fare il dj di
MTV semplicemente poi quando è arrivata
la mia età MTV nel senso almeno quel
ruolo lì è quella cosa lì non succedeva
più però ne faccio tantissimi altri
oltre alla radio che magari era qualcosa
ovviamente di trasversale che esiste da
sempre che invece ehm non non esistevano
il podcast era impensabile arrivare a
milioni di persone con dei contenuti era
decisamente in impensabile quindi questo
sicuramente è una risorsa di di questi
tempi e quindi questo mi ha portato
sempre a fare tante cose per cercare di
raggiungere i miei sogni i miei
obiettivi che ogni giorno tutti noi ci
poniamo no ci poniamo sempre anche un
po' di alzare l'asticella e per cercare
di fare tutte queste cose spesso il
percorso è è lungo anzi quasi sempre per
fare delle cose che soprattutto
lascino il segno Insomma che che che che
che abbiano un impatto ci vuole ci vuole
tempo e però se c'è una una costante in
tutte le cose che ho fatto fino ad oggi
è stata anche la voglia un po' di
condividerle ehm perché il mio percorso
iniziato bene o male quando è esploso il
mondo dei social Quando sono partiti i
primi social network quando è partito
YouTube quando è partito Instagram
Facebook poi a rotazione Però ognuno di
noi deve cercare in qualche modo di
intercettarli di capire come utilizzarli
e la costante anche in tutti questi
Social è appunto la la condivisione Io
credo fortemente nella condivisione
positiva ed è il motivo poi per cui sono
qui Qui oggi cioè quella condivisione
che in qualche modo
ti fa venire voglia di fare
qualcos'altro ti ispira no Io vivo di
quello mi nutro di ispirazione e il
fatto che magari qualcuno oggi mi dica
che io sono in ispirazione per lui o che
ha preso ispirazione da me per fare
delle cose è il mio orgoglio più grande
in assoluto ed è qualcosa che va oltre
no anche perché questo percorso spesso e
volentieri in tantissimi ambiti
professionali magari
nel mio modo anche maggiore in alcuni
casi è un percorso talmente
complesso e articolato per cui ci sono
ovviamente delle montagne russe
incredibile che se non hai una
motivazione forte un diciamo un
obiettivo più grande diventa difficile
se il tuo obiettivo è secondo diventare
famoso i soldi i followers e tutte
quelle robe lì Stai per certo che non
raggiungerai mai i tuoi sogni Se invece
il tuo obiettivo è qualcosa di più alto
probabilmente riuscirai a superare tutti
gli ostacoli il mio obiettivo era sempre
stato quello Insomma cercare di
rappresentare qualcosa per qualcuno E
questo grazie alla condivisione quindi
lungo questo percorso fatto come vi
dicevo di montagne russe ho sempre
condiviso tutto quindi ho iniziato
raccontando
le gioie i dolori fallimenti le cose che
andavano bene quelle che andavano bene
le persone che incontravo quelle che
conoscevo e questo nel tempo insomma mi
ha permesso di arrivare a tante persone
e essere stimolato a farne sempre di più
quindi insomma la mia vita è fatta
realmente chi mi segue lo sa sa che
magari vado ad allenarmi tutti i giorni
sa che finisco da una parte all'altra
del mondo ma poi devo tornare in tempo
per fare la diretta del mio programma in
radio Tipo oggi che sono qui ma fra due
ore sono in onda non so anch'io se ce la
farò Ma poi Accendete la radio
scopriremo se ce l'avrò fatta però
insomma questa continua voglia di fare
tante cose di non fermarmi mai è
diventata anche un po' la mia la mia
narrazione e qualcosa che mi tiene vivo
e alimenta la mia stessa passione perché
poi nella vita faccio questo cerco di
condividere le mie passioni in modo
autentico faccio tutte queste cose
tantissime cose di queste cose le
condivido però solo qualche anno fa mi
sono accorto Insomma ho realizzato che
forse la cosa che più aveva assegnato la
mia vita io non l'avevo mai condivisa e
allora
ho pensato o meglio sono successe una
serie di cose che mi hanno fatto pensare
che quel momento forse doveva arrivare
perché io tutte queste cose che vi ho
detto quindi anche tutto questo percorso
questa voglia di fare
in realtà anche tutto lo sport che che
faccio che vi racconto faccio tutto con
un defibrillatore impiantato sotto il
petto da quando c'ho 15 anni e che
quando il mio cuore arriva una soglia
definita dal Dai dottori questo
defibrillatore parte mi dà una scarica
fortissima e mi sbatte per terra Spero
che non succeda adesso perché sennò
diventerebbe un problema no è una cosa
che negli anni in realtà mi è successo
per farvi capire semplificando Avete
presente nei film quando c'è libera Ecco
succede questa cosa dentro di me Nel
senso che quando il cuore appunto arriva
a un determinato battito cardiaco troppo
elevato va in fibrillazione scossa cado
per terra Poi mi riprendo e adesso io
faccio facile però questa cosa
ovviamente nel corso dei tempi del tempo
è stato particolarmente
complessa soprattutto da accettare una
ritmica ventricolare di grave entità
l'ho scoperta giocando a basket che è
sempre stata una mia grande passione
quando avevo più o meno 15 anni durante
le partite Praticamente è una strana
coincidenza perché c'è il mischiarsi del
come dire lo stress emotivo e lo stress
fisico che ti può dare una prestazione
sportiva Quando queste due cose
coincidono in qualche modo il cuore fa
cortocircuito E appunto va su di giri
diciamo questa cosa l'ho scoperta
giocando per tanto tempo nessuno sapeva
facevo esami controlli nessuno sapeva e
riusciva a capire che cosa Vessi fino a
che durante una partita con un
dispositivo apposta si è si è capito
effettivamente quello che mi succedeva
il mio cuore smetteva di battere E poi
dopo un po' ripartiva e ed è una cosa Di
solito ti succede una volta nella vita
perché ci resti Quindi io sono stato
decisamente fortunato però questa
fortuna l'ho capita tanti anni dopo
perché in quel momento io la
semplicemente con una cosa assurda che
mi stava succedendo la cosa più il
dramma più grande della mia vita perché
avevo 15 anni a 15 anni se già
abbastanza incazzato con il mondo per i
fatti tuoi poi ti succede anche questo E
allora cercavo di capire quando appunto
cercavano di di sistemare quello che
avevo Insomma mi hanno fatto tutta una
serie di cose tecniche adesso sono
scendono nello specifico però delle
ablazioni dove entrano con una sonda non
da dove state pensando voi ma da un
altro punto dove In qualche modo cercano
di di eliminare quel Corto Circuito non
si riusciva perché io avevo questo
stress emotivo anche avevo la
sensibilità che mi fregava e infatti io
sto ricordo che durante
gli interventi che facevi da sveglio mi
facevano per cercarmi lo stress emotivo
mi chiedevano le tabelline dicevo Ma no
la matematica fa schifo Non è che mi fa
emozionare quindi non riuscivano a farmi
scattare L'unica cosa è stata mettere
questo defibrillatore che ovviamente
come vi dicevo ho avuto il rifiuto io
per anni non
per anni non lo accettavo continuavo a
dire No Ma va Ma io non ho niente ma
perché me lo adesso Facevo di tutto per
sfidare questa cosa per la gioia di mia
mamma che tra l'altro Oggi è la festa
della mamma faccio gli auguri a tutte le
mamme e mia mamma l'ho fatta disperare
un po' perché appunto in quel periodo
della mia vita correva a casa di corsa
per dimostrare che non hai niente
falsificavo certificati medici che è una
cosa sbagliatissima per la mia voglia
che avevo di sentirmi uguale agli altri
perché mi sentivo diverso ho avuto
attacchi di panico quando partiva la
scossa per dei giorni non volevo più
uscire di casa perché comunque avevo
quella quella paura lì di non capire che
cosa stava succedendo Ho annullato ogni
tipo di legame con il basket che era la
mia più grande passione proprio perché
soffrivo vedere gli altri giocare io non
potevo fare agonismo e quindi non potevo
dovevo in qualche modo smettere quindi
non l'ho mai detto a nessuno per per 17
anni praticamente proprio perché per più
motivi Il primo è perché
se non lo dici Non esiste quindi lo
sapevo Solo io non mi sentivo diverso
dagli altri poi perché non volevo che la
gente inizia a salire No Gianluca Stai
attento però eh Adesso se fai No no non
correre no no no no non andare veloce Ci
volevo pensare solo io e poi comunque
anche per il percorso Poi che ho
intrapreso non volevo che qualcuno
pensasse che in qualche modo io volessi
strumentalizzare o fare pena che è una
cosa che che che non piace neanche a me
quindi ho sempre detto nella vita
cercherò di dimostrare delle cose da
solo e poi quando sarà il momento giusto
lo racconterò e la cosa che poi mi ha
fatto molta
impressione anche quando poi questa cosa
l'ho raccontata perché io racconto le
mie scosse che sono quelle che mi
arrivano attraverso questo
defibrillatore che mi sono arrivate
lungo la vita ma ognuno ha le sue che
sono sotto forma di problemi di di di di
ostacoli che la vita in qualche modo ci
mette davanti e ognuno in qualche modo
poi le deve le deve superare e io questo
rifiuto poi l'ho superato in due
occasioni in particolare che proprio
quando poi ti scontri con la realtà e
capisci che magari non sei solo che ci
sono tante altre menate La prima è stata
durante un controllo perché questo
defibrillatore ogni tot una volta
all'anno vado a fare il controllo No
ogni volta Spero che esca il modello S
Plus più piccolo tipo Tipo l'iPhone
eccetera invece sempre uguale per Ora
vedremo la scienza dove ci porterà però
ho incontrato una una signora un'altra
madre in questo in questo caso che nel
vedere me si è confidata raccontandomi
del del figlio che aveva avuto la mia
stessa cosa avevano scelto di non
mettere le fibrillatore perché era una
scelta il figlio poi mancato e quindi
questa signora disperata e
successivamente un altro episodio che mi
ha fatto dire però Gianluca fermati un
attimo cerca di capire cosa stai facendo
è la perdita di una persona vicina che
aveva qualcosa di simile quindi ho detto
cacchio Ma allora forse non siamo
immortali Forse è meglio darci una una
calmata e in questo caso poi andando
avanti nel tempo
ho capito che era centri di raccontare
tutto questo quando un giorno mi hanno
chiamato a parole mi capita spesso
magari ogni tanto di prima che prima che
raccontassi questo anche di andare No
nelle scuole nelle Università di
raccontare un po' la mia esperienza
legata al mio lavoro al mio percorso
proprio perché c'è quel concetto di
ispirazione di cui vi parlavo e
quando mi sono ritrovato in questa
squadra con dei ragazzi per la prima
volta che avevano più o meno l'età che
avevo avuto io quando ho avuto la prima
volta il primo attacco
oltre a raccontare le mie esperienze li
ho visti molto attenti e ho raccontato
tutto ma ho raccontato tutto tutto
quello che ho che ho passato come l'ho
vissuto e quello che faccio che faccio
oggi e e li ho visti ipnotizzati subito
dopo mi hanno mandato un sacco di
messaggi per giorni ma Gianluca ma sai
che anch'io avevo una cosa simile adesso
che tu mi hai raccontato questo adesso
continuerò di qua a realizzerò i miei
sogni farò questo farò quest'altro
e mi sono reso conto che sta roba della
condivisione positiva è vera ed era
utilissima in quel momento anche per
quei ragazzi Quindi ho capito che era il
momento di raccontarlo la cosa che mi ha
fatto più impressione è che quando poi
l'ho raccontato pubblicamente perché poi
ho fatto un libro scritto un libro su
questo che si chiama appunto scosse
tutta la gente che mi segue ormai da
anni perché poi grazie a questa
condivisione si crea una un affetto
anche e mi han detto Ah ma allora Ecco
perché sei così Ah ma allora ecco perché
vivi la vita così Ah ecco perché fai
questo così intensamente cioè loro
avevano capito quello che io ci ho messo
33 anni più o meno a capire in un attimo
e hanno capito quello che ho capito io
collegando i puntini cioè che tutto
quello che mi aveva Insomma quello che
pensavo che mi stesse distruggendo la
vita quando avevo 15 anni in realtà è
tutto ciò che mi ha permesso
successivamente di realizzare i miei
sogni e spero di realizzarne ancora
tanti di fare tante cose cioè quella
sensibilità che mi fregava che mi faceva
stare male in campo e quella che poi mi
ha permesso di arrivare a tante persone
di creare Quale malattia con tante
persone che incontro per il mio lavoro e
tutto il pubblico che che mi segue è
quella quella determinazione la foga che
mettevo nello sport che mi faceva
esplodere il cuore Quella che mi ha
permesso di non mollare di continuare ad
essere determinato verso i miei
obiettivi e quindi è pazzesco a volte
come anche averlo condiviso poi mi ha
permesso di realizzare ancora di più
tutto tutto questo quindi io ci credo
fortemente in questa condivisione
positiva di cui vi ho parlato adesso la
vivo tutti i giorni la toccò con mano in
questi giorni in cui le cose sono stanno
andando molto bene di cui sono molto
contento la tocco ancora di più perché
alla fine nella vita tutto ti torna raga
torna tutto il male ma soprattutto il
bene e me ne sto accorgendo sempre di
più giorno dopo giorno e io vorrei che
questa storia Insomma quella che ho
raccontato che ormai racconto anche
abbastanza tranquillamente perché poi
raccontandola mi sono sentito di mi sono
reso conto di non essere
da solo io pensavo di essere l'unico
ragazzo giovane quello che è successa
una cosa di questo genere non è
assolutamente vero conosco tante persone
che invece adesso hanno visto quello che
faccio io che riesco a fare lo stesso e
non hanno più paura di uscire di casa e
quindi io stesso dico Cavolo Forse avrei
voluto avere un ragazzo che magari alla
mia età quando ero piccolo mi avesse
detto Ma sai che non tranquillo Cioè tu
non solo puoi fare quello che vuoi ma
farai anche di più di quello che puoi
immaginare e quindi questo l'ho trovato
assolutamente Ed estremamente potente
vorrei che questa storia insomma in
qualche modo servisse ad avere più
rispetto delle delle nostre paure di
quelle degli altri delle persone che
abbiamo intorno perché sono quelle paure
che ci rendono unici e soprattutto più
forti Io diciamo basato il mio percorso
sulla condivisione positiva ma
soprattutto su l'autenticità la
sincerità che credo che alla fine
paghino sempre ed è per questo grazie al
potere della condivisione positiva che
sono venuto qui oggi a raccontarvi la
mia storia Grazie mille
[Applauso]